[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god welcome to bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your bible
questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's
facts 800-463-7297
pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
on april 29 2020 a sprawling mass of
powerful thunderstorms produced a single
megaflash lightning strike over the
southern united states that was more
than
477 miles long
this record-breaking massive flash of
electric tentacles stretched from near
houston to southeast mississippi the
record beat the 440 mile long megaflash
that occurred over southern brazil on
halloween of 2018.
using the newest weather satellites the
world meteorological organization
announced that it had confirmed the mega
flash lightning record
the wmo also identified a world record
for the longest lasting lightning flash
it lit up the skies over uruguay and
northern argentina for 17.1 seconds on
june 18 2020. imagine that pastor ross
one lightning strike lights up the sky
for 17 seconds that may not sound like
long but
hold your breath and picture a lightning
strike for 17 seconds and
well that would put any dog under the
bed
just the brightness of that you could
probably read with a flash of lightning
that long you wonder what kind of
thunder it would produce oh man yeah
absolutely yeah you know what makes me
think about that verse in the bible
where jesus is warning regarding his
second coming he's warning about
not being deceived because he says
there's going to be false christs and
false prophets now let me read a little
bit uh to to you of this uh it's in
matthew 24 verse 23
through verse 27 then if anyone says to
you look here is christ or there
do not believe it for false christs and
false prophets will rise and show great
signs and wonders to deceive if possible
even the very elect
see i've told you beforehand
therefore if they say to you look he's
in the desert do not go out or look he's
in the inner rooms do not believe it for
as lightning comes from the east and
flashes to the west
so also will the coming of the son of
man be
and so he's telling us that we don't
need to be concerned about
um you know people say oh i'm jesus or
jesus came or you get a news report it
says it's going to be like the whole
heavens being lit up when he comes and
everybody's gonna know it i know pastor
you spent some time in the midwest i
have and uh boy do they have those
incredible electric storms
and sometimes when there's so much
lightning and thunder at night it just
lights up the sky it's just amazing well
you can imagine the coming of christ how
glorious that'll be there's no way you
can hide from that brightness of the
second coming of christ we have a book
talking about the second coming and it
says anything but secret that's the
title of the book you know sometimes
people are confused they wonder if the
second coming of christ is going to be
secret or quiet well the bible says just
the opposite it's going to be a noisy
glorious
event and we'll be happy to send this
book to anyone who asks the book of
queen is called anything but secret and
the number is
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line
you can ask for the book and we'll be
happy to send it to you if you're
outside of north america just go visit
the amazing facts website you'll be able
to read the book right there online
pastor like we want to greet our friends
who are joining us on facebook and
youtube also those watching on
amazingfactstv
as well as good news tv
and we know that you're typing in your
bible questions we're going to take some
time at the end of the program to answer
the written questions that have come in
so welcome also those listening on
satellite radio and various radio
stations
and we're glad you're part of our
program tonight well before we get to
the bible questions let's start with the
word of prayer dear father we thank you
for your word we thank you for the
opportunity to study the bible and we do
pray that your spirit can come and guide
us be with those who are listening lord
and lead us into a fuller and clearer
understanding what the bible says for we
ask this in jesus name amen amen all
right ready to go to that first call of
this evening we've got tim listening
from michigan tim welcome to the program
tim in michigan
hi tim you there thank you
yep yeah how can we help you tonight
um well um a little while ago a fellow
called in and asked it's the rapture and
the second coming was the same thing
and you said yes
and i was just wondering about that um
there's a couple of the day of the lord
you you know you gave him uh
first thessalonians 4.
and this kind of refers to
zechariah's prophecy when his feet touch
the mount of olives i was wondering if
there was a timeline between that
between the rapture and when
what that prophecy was about yes there
is a time given if you uh so we're going
to mute you a little bit timmy we hear
that someone else is trying to join you
on that call
but um yeah the bible tells us that
there's actually a span of about a
thousand years
uh called the millennium the bible
refers to it as a thousand years between
the first resurrection and the second
resurrection now when jesus feet touch
the mount of olives as you find in
zechariah chapter 14 verse 4 says his
feet will stand on that day on the mount
of olives which is before jerusalem on
the east and the mount of olives shall
cleave in the midst thereof now one
reason you know this is not when jesus
comes
for the rapture the bible says during
the rapture he doesn't touch the ground
we are caught up to meet him and he says
i will take you to the mansions that i
prepared and that's john chapter 14. but
here he's actually touching the earth so
this is when he some might call it the
third coming he's coming back after the
millennium
and his feet touch the mount of olives
massive earthquake creates a great
valley
and the new jerusalem actually settles
in that valley then later and you read
it also in this chapter the the wicked
launch and attack you see that also in
revelation 20 against the city of god
and fire comes down from god out of
heaven and devours them
so yes there is actually a 1 000 year or
the millennial period between
his next coming
and this uh period at the end of the
1000 years in zechariah 14. you know we
do have a study guide that talks about
the 1000 years spoken of in revelation
chapter 20 and we'll be happy to send
this to you tim or anyone who calls and
asks it's called a thousand years of
peace
the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
and again you can ask for that study
guide it's called a thousand years of
peace if you have a bible related
question the phone line here to the
studio is
we've got 800-463-7297 marvis listening
from monterio uh marvis welcome montreal
rather
hello yes you on the air
okay um first of all thank you and for
you
because for both of you for uh
accounting me to ask you my question
yes
so
um
my question
before i ask him i know you
uh you can answer every question if you
don't have the answer right now
uh or yet it's okay uh i will understand
because it's a hard question
um
so my question is
when the door of operation will close
okay now for our friends listening when
someone is talking about probation
closing they're referring to a time when
life may still go on here briefly on
earth but the saved are all saved and
the lost are all lost and there's nobody
changing teams anymore the people who
are saved are sealed and saved pastor
ross there's that verse in revelation 22
where he says uh those that are just let
them be just phil still and i'll i'll
i'll tell you about another passage
that's in
genesis when noah
was told with his family to enter into
the ark he entered into the ark and god
shut the door
all of the animals and noah that were
going to be saved were in the ark the
door was shut all the lost were on the
outside and their destiny was sealed
life went on for a few more days seven
days in this story and then the reins
came
so
there may be a period of time a brief
period just before jesus comes when all
the saved are saved and all the lost are
lost and there's no changing sides
anymore the other verse referring to is
revelation 22 11 it says he who is
unjust let him be unjust
he who is filthy let him be filthy still
he who is righteous let him be righteous
still he who is holy let him be holy
still and then the very next verse says
and behold i am coming quickly and my
reward is with me to give to everyone
according to his works so the close of
probation here
takes place just before the second
coming of christ
and most people believe that when the
plagues begin to fall
that at that point the holy spirit has
been withdrawn from the wicked and
that's why they get you know kind of
berserking in their attempt to
annihilate all christians
when the seven last plagues are falling
at that point we believe the saved are
saved and the loss are lost and
probation is closed
okay thank you for your call uh madeline
is listening from kansas madeline
welcome to the program
thank you thank you so much for
answering my call i really appreciate it
and i love your show thank you okay so
i've got a
quickish question so in the book of ezra
chapter 10
um i don't know exactly how to word it
the lady who took my call she helped me
a bit i know how i feel about it and
that's the confusion regarding it
so the foreign women and children they
were to be dismissed from the
congregation
apparently the jewish men were not
supposed to do this they took foreign
women etc
but my question is was there no
provision no way for for those women the
ones who accepted yahweh as their own
god i mean we do see examples of ruth
and rahab
why did these women you know have to be
dismissed i mean i guess i know why the
real question is was there a way that
they could have been
allowed to stay
and not been sent away
yeah this is a difficult passage and
just for our friends that are listening
you find this in ezra chapter 10 and it
talks about it in
well it mentions them by name when you
get to verse 18
but the the whole reason they'd been
carried off into captivity is they had
compromised their beliefs and stopped
worshiping god and began to worship
idols so now after learning their lesson
70 years they come back to rebuild the
temple rebuild the city and the leaders
start to marry pagan wives again
and ezra is going this is how we got
into trouble
now these are pagan wives that are still
worshiping pagan gods it's kind of like
you know ahab was influenced by jezebel
ruth had accepted the god of naomi and
rahab had accepted the god of salman and
the other spy well there's two spies we
think one of them was named salman
it doesn't tell us in the passage that
these wives had accepted jehovah
so that's one thing another thing is if
they were told to put them away keep in
mind abraham was told to put away hagar
but he gave her an allowance when he put
her he put her away
you know they call that alimony today or
some support
but you know it was causing all kinds of
havoc in the family this was a very
drastic measure because the whole nation
was at the point of a new birth and the
new birth was going to be destroyed by
these intermarriages with pagans once
again so they took pretty drastic
measures
all right well thank you for your call
thank you madeline hope that helps a
little bit
we've got sid listening from maryland
sid welcome to the program
hi how are you good thanks for calling
um so my question is
why were people getting baptized before
jesus got baptized because when people
get baptized now they say that you are
taking a stand for jesus
and by getting baptized jesus set an
example for his followers
well the first baptism was called the
baptism of john which was a baptism of
repentance so john the baptist was not
saying i baptize you in the name of the
father son and holy spirit john the
baptist was not saying i baptize you in
the name of jesus
john was baptizing them in the name of
jehovah
you know to just have a repentance and a
return to god an example of this is
found in acts chapter 19
paul meets 12 ephesian believers
and he's preaching about jesus and they
said well we haven't heard about this he
says well have you heard about the holy
spirit and they said we didn't know
if there was a holy spirit
and paul says into what then were you
baptized they said john's baptism
meaning john the baptist
so john baptized for probably a year and
a half before he identified jesus as the
lamb of god
john then continued with his disciples
to baptize until he was arrested
probably only about six months after
that
and so am i answering your question sid
about uh what was the distinction there
yes
okay very good yeah so then you know
once john recognized jesus as the lamb
of god john said he must increase i must
decrease you know he had done his work
calling the nation to repentance the
people were turning back to god and then
he kind of did a handoff to jesus
you know talking about baptism it's an
important uh subject pastor doug and the
bible has a lot to say about it we have
a book it's called baptism is it really
necessary again there's sort of divided
opinion today even amongst christians as
to baptism when is a person to be
baptized is it really necessary for
salvation how to do it yeah what name
yeah the whole thing yeah a lot of
confusion so we'll be happy to send this
book to anyone who calls and asks it's
called baptism is it really necessary
the number to call for that is
four 800-835-6747 and if you're in north
america we'll get in the mail send it to
you if you're outside of north america
you can read it by going to the amazing
facts website just amazingfacts.org and
of course if you're in north america you
can also go to the website and you'll be
able to read it there thanks for your
call we've got uh let's see
uh angela he's calling from illinois
angela welcome to the program
hi
hi dr uh hi pastor ross and um
after doug um i have a question in the
new testament
was it the pharisees or the sadducees
that did the sacrifices i know that um
in the old testament the levi's were um
through the through aaron right on the
heritage but
um and then i have a follow-up after
christ's death uh with sacrifices still
being conducted
um
you know because of course he was the
sacrifice but i just i don't read that
and so um yeah good question
all right let's see if we can i think we
can answer both of those pretty quickly
um as far as the pharisees and sadducees
neither the pharisees and sadducees
really served in the temple
to baptize to offer sacrifice
um
you could be a pharisee but you had to
be a levite now you could have a levite
that was a pharisee meaning
that they were um the pharisees were the
devoted ones they were consecrated in a
special way they they weren't going to
pollute themselves with paganism now
there were some levites that also
followed the pharisee rules but you
could be a pharisee and not a levite
like paul was a benjamite so paul never
offered sacrifice same thing with the
sadducees but many of the sadducees were
from the priestly family like kaifus
so here they are offering sacrifice but
some of them didn't even believe in
angels or resurrection which is really
pathetic
at the time of christ the church had
fallen pretty
pretty badly and the second part of your
question did they still sacrifice after
jesus died on the cross
well the veil was rent
when jesus died on the cross they
probably had to you know repair the the
veil but they probably reinstituted the
form of a sacrifice
up until the temple was destroyed by the
romans
you know there's another verse talking
about that pastor when when
jesus left the temple for the last time
he said to the religious leaders and to
the jews your house has left you
desolate meaning that he had disowned
the sanctuary and thus the sacrificial
service because he was the lamb of god
right and then there's a prophecy that
you find in daniel chapter 9 that's
talking about christ the messiah and it
says he will put an end to sacrifices
and it's talking about his death right
so there's a number of old testament
passages and also in the new testament
it's at the death of christ there was no
need for a sacrifice jesus was the lamb
of god that takes away the sins of the
world so but they still probably went
through the form of a sacrificial system
until the temple was destroyed but it
was meaningless at that point right
thank you appreciate your call
next quarter that we have is robert
listening from uh new jersey
robert are you there yeah yeah good
after good evening pastor can you hear
me yes
okay great
um my question is concerning what's the
first lie recorded
in the in the bible now this says um
and the the full amend which is uh
uh genesis three
uh
three i think it's three four
where the serpent says to uh the woman
uh you will not surely die
that's usually considered the first lie
that was
that was recorded but then somebody
pointed something out
when she was a discus having a
discussion with the serpent
so you must not eat from the fruit of
the tree this is um genesis 3
4 i believe with me through it
you must not
you must i eat
fruit from the tree but you must not not
even touch it with your god now
that's um
we don't hear that when uh god's saying
it to adam so
did she make that up or did or did was
that added on later
or did she did she get confused what
what's um
what would that be was she lying or
okay yeah it sounds like it sounds like
eve is adding something to the
instruction that you see earlier where
god says you're not to eat from the tree
and uh i don't think eve made it up
because they there was no sin until she
ate the forbidden fruit her heart was
pure and innocent she had no reason to
lie or deceive
i think she was expanding on or rather i
think she was giving more information
on what god had told adam and eve keep
in mind the bible is summarizing i'm
sure that god said many things to adam
the bible tells us you know god and adam
spent that day together naming all the
animals so
i'm sure there were many things that god
said
um the way that you know it's first
recorded for us as god says don't eat
from it when you hear from eve we
realize god not only said don't eat from
it he said don't touch it so you stay
away from it
of course touching it led to eating from
it and so they kind of
you know the reason you would touch the
fruit is because you wanted to pick it
and eat it so i think that there's not a
lie involved on eve's part there i think
she's absolutely sincere when she's
talking to the serpent
all right thank you so cool we've got
the abdiel listening from florida abdiel
welcome to the program
all right thank you for having me how
are you guys good thanks for calling
thank you uh so i just had a quick thank
you so
i found your program in december and
it's made a big difference
oh raises a lot of questions
so i had a question
i mean luke
so in luke uh
it seems like there's a very earnest man
called simeon
and it seems like he already knows that
the messiah is coming in his lifetime
right and i think there's a couple
others that that could have happened to
maybe like anna i hear
uh so i guess
the question is for both of you john
ross and password
uh so
is it possible that
to have that kind of relationship with
jesus today that
you know if you're diligent that he can
tell you
basically like hey and you might not
tell you a date
but he can tell you like
in your lifetime or something so i'm not
really sure how that goes but
yeah it seems like you know the lord of
course gave a divine revelation to the
shepherds
about jesus coming and there was a
divine revelation that was given to the
wise men
of christ's
coming
and then simeon said the lord had told
him that you'll not taste of death until
you see it you know and he said now let
your servant depart in peace for i've
seen his salvation could that happen
again before the second coming
i you know god is not restricted the
lord could impress anybody that um you
know you're not going to die before you
see these things be fulfilled
that would not replace scripture
and god is not going to give the day and
the hour to anybody because jesus is
very clear no man knows the day of the
hour
but can god give an impression that uh
sure he's the lord he's not restricted
and even after jesus ascended to heaven
you know he appeared to uh paul
and to some others and so
jesus still communicates with people
today
you mentioned simeon as well as anna she
was also the one that um
confessed christ to be the messiah as a
baby the bible does tell us in luke
chapter 2 verse 36 that anna was a
prophetess so that's right god had
spoken to her through dreams or visions
but either way whether it was through a
direct revelation or through the
prompting of the holy spirit
these two individuals had a very special
very close
connection and communion with god
and of course their hope especially for
simeon was lord let me uh see the
promised messiah before i die
and god honored that and he got to see
baby jesus that's right amen
well thank you hope that helps a little
abdiel appreciate your call and
encourage you keep listening
we've got karen listening in texas karen
welcome to the program
thank you
okay my question is
i had heard
that
jesus wasn't born in just a regular barn
but that he was born in
the special
barn where their perfect
sheep
was
taken care of
before they were going to be used for a
sacrifice
okay and you wanted to know what the
bible says about that
yes had you heard that
um
i had not heard that i've heard several
things about you know some people that
try to extrapolate on giving more
details about the birth of jesus
but the bible simply says that um she
brought forth her firstborn son
and called his name jesus and they laid
him they wrapped him in swaddling
clothes and they laid him in a manger
because there was no room in the inn
so the assumption is a manger is a
trough
in which you feed animals
and it's interesting a trough is where
you hold grain
and jesus who is the bread of life was
placed in a bread basket you might say
and he was born in a town called
bethlehem and the word bethlehem means
house of bread so here you have the
bread of life put in a bread basket born
in the town that is called the house of
bread
and that in itself is interesting the
other thing is that
this is sort of a reverse
of what happened at the death of jesus
the birth of jesus he enters the world
the the
troughs they use the mangers they use
for food uh in spite of what you might
see christmas time on a corner they
usually carve them out of stone
a donkey will chew up a wooden trough i
used to have horses
so they carved them out of stone
and the manger
could have been located in a cave around
bethlehem it's a very rocky country and
a lot of people say it wasn't a barn as
you think of you know on the
east coast of the u.s they got these big
red barns but it was probably more like
a cave where the animals would stay out
of the rain
and so
some have wondered isn't that
interesting that
when jesus entered the world he was
placed in a stone box
and wrapped in cloth
and he came to life at the end of his
life he's placed in a
a virgin tomb that had never been used
before jesus was put in a virgin womb
and that he was wrapped in cloth
there's a joseph at the birth of jesus
and there's a joseph at the death of
jesus and it's just uh it's kind of
interesting so we you know i doubt it
was a typical barn it may have been a
cave it may have been a shed
but where the animals were protected the
bible doesn't say so everything anyone
says about it is pure speculation
go into detail yeah the bible gives very
little detail just says she brought
forth her son and they placed them in a
manger because there was no room in the
end hey thank you karen we sure
appreciate your calling and i hope you
call back again
our pastor do we have time for one more
call before we
get a quick question maybe let's go to
bradley in arizona bradley welcome to
the program we have about a minute and a
half before the break
i say on revelation 22 2
my question is if we're in heaven and we
have glorified bodies and we have access
to the tree of life
why do we need the leaves for the
healing of the nations
yeah and it actually says in ezekiel and
the leaves of the tree are for medicine
and why would we need medicine well you
know the way it's worded here in
revelation it doesn't say the leaves of
the tree are for the healing of sickness
it says healing of nations
and you know now here in this world
people are all divided by their their
languages and their cultures and their
races and
in heaven those divisions will not exist
as we all gather under that massive tree
of life
um under its shimmering leaves and eat
from that fruit that helps perpetuate
life
that all of the divisions that have
separated the nations here in this world
will be dissolved
and so it almost makes it sound like
it's the healing of the nations there's
going to be no sickness in the kingdom
and there may be some
[Music]
some he not healing is not the right
word but there might be some vitalizing
power to the leaves
you know what happened to popeye when he
ate spinach
so yeah
you can't rule it out god's got i think
every part of the tree is going to be
edible
so
they say they got that what is it the
baobab tree there in africa and
australia that you can eat its fruit you
can eat its sap you can eat its leaves
when they're young they're like spinach
it's just every part of it is a tree of
life so don't know that might be the
answer tim anyway hey thank you very
much for your question don't go away
friends we're going to take a break
we're going to come back in a few
moments we've got more questions lined
up we see those of you who are standing
in line hang on
and endure to the end we'll get to your
phone calls
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95-minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today
visit itunes or afbookstore.com
life can be overwhelming where can an
on-the-go woman find quality time with
god the new amazing treasures of faith
box set from amazing facts empowers your
devotional life with inspiring resources
that will bring lasting peace into your
busy life this beautifully designed box
set by women for women comes with a 31
day devotional recipe and scripture
cards and special messages from pastor
doug and karen batchelor get your
amazing treasures of faith box set today
just call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown
these are the images people generally
associate with the tribulation and the
day of the lord
but did you know the bible speaks about
another day of the lord just before the
great judgment day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being
a day the entire world is largely
forgotten
you'll be surprised to learn how this
special day of the lord factors into
last day prophecies such as the mark of
the beast the seal of god and the great
final tribulation
it's all contained in this new
eye-opening dvd series called the last
day of prophecy
to order call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and this program is here
for that purpose to do our best to
answer your bible questions so if you
have a bible question you can give us a
call the number 800 god says 800
800-463-7297
and we're going to get back to the
phones my name is pastor doug batchelor
my name is john ross and we got faye
listening in washington faye welcome to
the program
hi
hi how can we help you yeah loud and
clear
um i was just wondering if you could
kind of explain the antichrist
um
we'll do our best what what exactly it
is yeah and then like other you know
religions
different churches being in heaven
different religions okay
yeah well first of all will there be
well i believe there'll be
christians from many denominations in
the kingdom so the idea that only one
denomination has a
copyright on the kingdom of heaven
i do think it matters what you believe
but i think that god has sincere people
that are
in many christian persuasions
on the first question about the
antichrist now you find the word
antichrist five times in the bible
interestingly it is not found at all in
revelation or daniel it's found in 1st
john four times the first letter of john
and in second john it's found once
and notice what he says here
it tells us that um
my little children this is first john uh
let me see this is verse 18 of chapter 2
first john chapter 2 verse 18 little
children it is the last hour and you've
heard that antichrist is coming even now
many antichrists
have come by which we know it's the last
hour
so even in the antichrist means against
or opposed to
so there were leaders back then powerful
leaders that were opposed to christ one
of them actually put john in boiling oil
and god miraculously survived
but the main antichrist that we we find
that is this little horn power from
daniel chapter uh
seven and eight
and uh
eleven
um
that has been identified most protestant
christians identified that with the
papacy
and i know folks are shocked to hear
that but i'm just telling you that
if you look at john wesley and john
calvin martin luther charles spurgeon
you just kind of go up through the
history of the great protestant
preachers they said you cannot escape
that that beast power that you find for
example if you look in revelation
chapter 17 talks about a woman and
that's a church
that has become unfaithful
sits among seven hills romans the city
of seven hills has a golden cup in her
hand the golden chalice for the mass is
considered the most sacred vessel and
they looked at chapter 17
of revelation by itself they said this
is that antichrist power so i know that
doesn't
that sounds like you know hate speech
but i'm just telling you what the
protestants how they interpreted
prophecy we have a lesson on that we do
it's called who is the antichrist and i
think faith you'd enjoy to anyone
wanting to learn more about what the
bible says this is pretty deep prophecy
so
um it's important though the bible talks
about these various powers and kingdoms
and countries in the last days we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks the number to call is
800-835-6747
you can ask for the study guide it's
called who is the antichrist and we'll
send that to anyone who calls and asks
next quarter that we have is daniel
listening in colorado daniel welcome to
the program
hi uh
i have
have a question how do we know if the
dinosaurs
uh were dead in noah's flood
okay
um
now we know a lot of animals died not
just dinosaurs but lions and tigers and
bears died in noah's flood the only ones
that were saved were the ones that were
brought on the ark
the unclean animals those that could not
be used for either food or sacrifice
they came
by twos and the clean animals came by
sevens now when you say dinosaur a
dinosaur these big thunder lizards and
uh
they're giant reptiles uh they're a
whole species of creatures that are
extinct now
you could argue and say well we still
have crocodiles and we still have
you know
what do they call them um
these giant monitor lizards and the
commoded dragons and almost like kubota
tractors
and so you've got all kinds of
great reptiles that are still in the
world today there also used to be giant
mammals
uh you know they they had
what was it sloths that were 13 feet
tall and beavers that were eight feet
and just a lot of mammals that were in
bison that was big as a house so all of
the creatures kind of were shrunk uh
during the flood
uh i did you read in the new testament
i'm sorry you read following the flood
there was this mighty hunter named
nimrod
and mighty hunters don't hunt mice
mighty hunters hunt big animals it could
be that noah had preserved two of some
of these
greater reptiles
and they all got killed off like the
dodo birds they were extinct
so um you know they're all gone now
and uh all we've got is the fossils of
some of these giant reptiles and even
mammals
but thank you you know uh we've got a
book we've got a a book that you would
enjoy daniel it's it's got pictures too
about the dinosaurs it's our magazine by
jim pinkowski and uh if you go to the
amazing facts website type in dinosaurs
and you'll see our color it's kind of
like a comic book bible study i think if
you're seven years old you'll really
enjoy that
all right thanks for your call daniel
we've got lee listening from north
carolina lee welcome to the program
oh thank you so much hi pastors my
question please is about the holy spirit
i know that after jesus left he sent the
holy spirit to the apostles
my question is what about the old
testament prophets and
you know just god's faithful jehovah's
faithful did they have the spirit i mean
did they just have it and not know it i
mean i guess the trinity
started right at the beginning
i know jesus was prophesied about right
from the garden of eden but i just
didn't know when does the holy spirit
enter thank you so much yeah thanks for
your question we sure appreciate it faye
uh you the holy spirit has been around
of course since the beginning there in
genesis where it tells us the spirit
moved upon the face of the waters right
there at the beginning and you go to the
last book in the bible the last chapter
it says the spirit and the bride say
come
and you read you know in the old
testament it tells us the spirit of the
lord came upon samson
and then you read where
moses brought 70 elders to mount sinai
to present them before the lord and the
lord put his holy spirit upon them that
actually says he took the spirit that
was on moses and put it upon them
meaning
god's spirit that god had given moses
the same spirit
and when the bible tells us that elisha
prayed for a double portion of elijah's
spirit well that was the holy spirit
and david when he says in psalm 51
take not thy holy spirit from me
so there are many many passages in the
old testament where you see the spirit
of god now you don't see the degree of
the baptism of the holy spirit that
jesus gave the apostles until after the
sacrifice of christ
the power and the miracles that were
wrought by the disciples was
unparalleled by virtually any old
testament character save moses and
elijah but here he had 12 spirit-filled
prophets going out and preaching about
jesus
so in other words you're saying pastor
like the holy spirit has always been
active since the creation he's been
speaking to the hearts of man the bible
says it's the goodness of god that leads
us to repentance so the holy spirit was
speaking to the hearts of people even
before christ came uh there were some
god-fearing people who loved the lord
and of course miracles did occur in the
old testament as well
some mighty miracles even been resurrect
resurrected from the dead yeah the word
the word spirit is found 617 times in
the bible and many of them are old
testament references
all right thank you faye hope that helps
a little bit and we do have a book that
talks about the need of the holy spirit
you can download that uh or ask for it
for free the number to call is
800-835-6747 and again you can ask for
that book it's called the holy spirit
the need and we'll be happy to send that
to anyone who calls and asks next caller
that we have is kevin listening from uh
mississippi kevin welcome to the program
hello
we can sounds like you're on the road so
uh you might want to ask your question
yes hi uh so i was just wondering
when a person when do a person read
about paul
okay good question
if a person falls
at what point do they need to be
re-baptized now
a person can fall off a step and they
usually don't get too hurt if you fall
off a cliff it's more serious there's
different kinds of falls
it's normal for a christian
as you're following the lord to uh slip
you know james says uh in many things we
offend
and uh as the sparks fly upwards so the
children of men are prone towards doing
things wrong so it's it's commonplace
for christians to sin in
thought or action it should not be the
pattern of their life
and that's why we we pray and we repent
and we look for god's ongoing mercy john
tells us if we
sin
to confess our sins and he's faithful
and just to forgive us our sins and
cleanse us
and then we have the lord's supper as
sort of a new beginning that's like
another level
where we
partake of that grape juice representing
the blood of christ and the bread
representing the body of christ
and in some churches like ours they even
participate in foot washing service
so we try to reenact that new beginning
so for in most cases when a person you
know
they make a mistake they might want to
just look forward to that communion
service and get a new beginning if a
person divorces themselves from the lord
they stop going to church
they stop confessing christ
and they drift away when they come back
and they want to make sure that they're
committed and they're back
they may need to be remarried
and
that would be and you've got examples of
this
uh in a few places in the bible but
um we have a book on baptism that will
probably answer that question the book
is called baptism is it really necessary
and again talks about baptism also
re-baptism we'll be happy to send that
to anyone who calls an ass the number
again 800-835-6
asks for the book we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls
thank you for your call kevin we've got
helen listening in florida helen you're
on the air
hi thank you for taking my call hi thank
you
my question is it's concerning um
revelation
chapter 21 verses 9 and 10.
um i i guess i just need clarification
on on the bride of christ like who who
is the bride of christ
okay revelation
yeah go ahead you want me to read this
for people
oh sure yeah so we uh let me just read
this it says then one of the seven
angels this is revelation chapter 21
verse 9
one of the seven angels who had the
seven bowls filled with the seven last
plagues came to me and talked with me
saying come i will show you the bride
the lamb's wife and he carried me away
in the spirit to a great and high
mountain and he showed me the great city
the holy jerusalem descending out of
heaven from god
so
the dwelling place for the people of god
is the new jerusalem so it calls in new
jerusalem the bride it's not the
buildings it's the people that will live
in the buildings and so
in the old testament they sometimes
referred to jerusalem as the city of god
well god is not marrying stone and
two-by-fours and plaster
it was the people that lived in the city
and so
the new jerusalem again is the people
the church now one reason we know this
is if you look in ephesians chapter 5 i
think pastor rossford says
husbands love your wives even as christ
loved the church
and gave himself for her
so we are to love our wives as christ
loves the church the church is like the
bride of christ yeah that's ephesians
chapter 5 is 25. there you go you know
one other thought on that the new
jerusalem is described as the bride of
christ of course pastor doug said is
going to be populated by the redeemed
but jesus also promised the kingdom the
bible talks about a new heavens and a
new earth wherein dwells righteousness
and jesus is going to be the king of
kings and lord of lords the capital of
this new kingdom on earth at the end of
the thousand years when the earth which
we created is going to be the new
jerusalem and the amazing thing is not
only is the new jerusalem the capital of
a world recreated but the bible tells us
that god is going to be in the city
christ is going to be in the city in
essence it becomes the capital of the
entire universe the place that had
fallen
into sin
redeemed now through the sacrifice of
christ is elevated as the center of the
universe because god's going to dwell
with these people that's an incredible
thing amen and you know i think we have
a lesson that's called the bride of
christ we do yeah we happen to send that
out again the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
just ask for that book it's called the
bride of christ one of our amazing facts
study guides and you'll enjoy reading
that it's got a number of great passages
from scripture talking about that
subject
thanks for call helen we've got chris
listening from uh
listening here in the us hi chris
welcome to the program
hi guys how are you good
good so i'm not really sure how to word
this question but i'm a baby christian
just since august of last year but my
question is
would it be a characteristic of god to
allow a marriage
born out of sin
to end
and then use those two people uh newly
converted or one of them newly converted
for his purpose and then bring that
marriage back together built on a godly
foundation
well
i want to make sure i understand your
question so you're asking if um you've
got
uh
a couple one is converted
they are married
and can are they're separated and
they're coming back together again can
god use them can you try and maybe
restate that again because i i didn't
catch what you were saying
yep so you have two people who entered
into marriage uh built on sin okay in
the beginning
and uh so god dismantled that marriage
and allowed the divorce
and now one of them is converted
and being used for god's purpose or
god's will
and then god brings them back together
after he's through or or brings them
back together
on his timing would that be a
characteristic of god
well i think that if you've got two
people and they were married and they
it fell apart for whatever reason and
one of them is converted if they're
legally divorced if they're one of
them's thinking of remarrying i wouldn't
remarry unless they're both agreed
on being christians
can god do that he absolutely can
but i would not re-enter into a marriage
where only one was converted
if they're already legally divorced
so
uh it'd be great you know if they you're
still friends and you can do bible
studies together and
if you could come back together and that
can be a testimony i've seen that happen
before
so yeah can god do that he absolutely
can
we got a book i'm talking about the
subject of marriage it's called marriage
divorce and remarriage and i think it'll
answer a lot of your questions the
number to call for that is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
marriage divorce and remarriage
thanks for your call chris we've got uh
jamima listening from canada
jamima welcome to the program
pretty mean pastor rod and dr dog
so my question is um
this god um allows us to be punished
when we are being
arrogant and both full
and if we mock the lord because
i uh come the book of daniel i read here
um daniel 4 verse 23 to 27 this is
talking about
the seven years of the illness of king
nebuchadnezzar so
god
made um
king nebuchadnezzar insane or mad for
being so
um bossful
yes
it certainly is true that god often
punishes pride pride was the first great
sin of the devil
and it tells us in proverbs a haughty
spirit goes before a fall pride goes
before destruction and a haughty spirit
before a fall
you can read in the bible where king
herod
was boasting in acts chapter 12
and he was taking the the prerogatives
and the worship that belongs to god and
the angel of the lord struck him
and he died
and you can see where the pharaoh
hardened his heart through pride and he
was judged and punished
and
you've got the proud pharisee who says i
thank you on better than other men
so the pride is one of the most
offensive things to god and the lord
wants to save us from pride all of us
struggle with pride in varying degrees
but um it's very hard for the lord to
reach an arrogant person that's why he
wants us to humble ourselves it says the
meek will inherit the earth there's a
verse in proverbs chapter 16 verse 18
that says pride goes before destruction
and a haunted spirit before a fall
that's pretty clear right there
all right thanks for your call juma
we've got ashley listening in washington
ashley welcome to the program
hi thank you for having me yes
and your question hi so i just had
yeah i have a different question
actually for this evening um i'm just
wondering if it is appropriate to decode
the book of psalms i've been seeing a
lot of different pastors talking about
it and i'm just wondering if it's
appropriate or biblical
so are you talking about where they
sometimes take the hebrew letters and
they say the hebrew letters in psalms
have different
numerical value and there's prophetic
meaning when you look at them that way
or are you talking about when they find
messianic prophecies in the book of
psalms
um a little bit of both the big one i've
been seeing is that psalms is
the
um
19th book in and the 48th from the end
so leading to 1948 and that psalms 48
leads to the
the rebirth of jerusalem and they've
tied a bunch of other prophecies to it i
just wasn't sure if
it's difficult to go off that or okay
i'm glad you clarified it yet yeah what
you've just described there
is uh it's kind of like bible study
voodoo i i don't think that god intended
for us to take the chapter numbers and
try to make anything out of that chapter
numbers were not part of
the uh you know the inspired
a message that god is giving us
um and you so if you start taking
chapter numbers in the psalms the way
they were arranged you know different
some actually have reigns of psalms
where they take the psalms of david and
they put them in a different category
with the psalms of solomon and the
psalms of hezekiah
the way we get it in the king james
version they're all bundled together
but to start trying to interpret the
psalm numbers in chapters and verses
where you're mixing up the numerology
and trying to create
secret messages
that's just uh yeah that's that's like
bible bingo i i don't think there's any
message in that at all
now what does blow us away the psalms
are supernatural when you read in psalm
22 where it says they pierced my hands
and my feet and they gambled for my
clothing and dogs have surrounded me
that's an incredible prophecy that talks
about jesus on the cross
so those things are very powerful
but to start mixing up the numbers and
trying to get messages out of that and
make dates and
nah
i'd stay away from that
i hope that helps a little bit
all right thank you
we've got uh david listening from
illinois david welcome to the program
hello pastors how you all doing tonight
doing great thanks for calling
uh
my question is about the last generation
um
i guess the best way i can put it is uh
with adam and eve
when they eat that when they had eaten
the forbidden fruit
god told adam
for this day you shall surely die
well one day for
god was like a thousand years for
abdomen he lived to be what 900
what
930 years
okay
and then with moses
he told moses
that he can see the promised land but he
cannot enter it so when he did see it he
died right after
the same thing with the uh priest that
saw the that saw baby christ he was told
that he would see the christ
and right after that he died
so i
guess the heart of my question would be
with the last generation that shall not
die
how will that play out will it be like
with the last person
of the
last generation or what
it's a question i've been contemplating
for quite a while
all right thank you so much david
appreciate your question um you know it
is fascinating that god told adam in the
day that you eat thereof you will die
and yet the bible tells us in
uh second peter chapter 3 a day with the
lord is like a thousand years and a
thousand years like a day
and
peter's actually quoting from one of the
psalms where it says a thousand years in
his sight or as an an evening that is
gone
and so
uh god said to adam and eve you're gonna
die in the day well they began to die
spiritually as soon as they sinned the
death process began a matter of fact it
tells us i think in the hebrew in dying
you will die so it's a dying process
will begin
but they didn't make it to that first
millennium that first thousand years if
a thousand years is like a day adam and
but even methuselah and all the
patriarchs died before they reached that
first millennial day
but as far as the last generation
i think there's going to be a lot of
people still alive when jesus comes he's
going to protect them and bring them out
of this world just like he saved the
children of israel out of egypt and he
protected them from the ten plagues
he'll protect a lot of people from the
seven last plagues what do you think
pastor ross can we squeeze in one more
yes i think so let's go to michael in
montana michael welcome to the
program uh good evening pastors can you
hear me we can we've just got about a
minute oh so can we do it i know um it's
a speculative question um
say adam and eve did obey god and and
pass all the tests that satan threw at
them from the tree
um
what would have happened
to satan and his angels would god have
thrown them in some corner or they would
have just disintegrate i mean this is
speculation but i've been thinking about
this okay well it's fair enough you're
right it is kind of a speculating
question because it's you know you can
have a hypothesis of what would happen
it's hard to know without having the
mind of god and being able to interview
him
but it could be that if every if every
world had passed the tests i believe god
is of their own fallen worlds that satan
probably tried to recruit but he found
supporters down here if every other
world had passed the test and satan
couldn't find any other followers
god probably would have
just destroyed satan and his angels
because it says in
matthew 25 that the the angel and his
devils will be thrown in this way
matthew 25 41. yeah so their destruction
was sealed and
but the way it works now is anybody that
follows the devil is going to join him
hey thank you so much michael appreciate
that we do have a lesson called did god
create a devil and it touches on that
subject and the number to call for that
is
800-835-6747 again you can ask for the
study guide it's called did god create
the devil
now friends just so you understand
what's happening here we broadcast on
land-based stations and we broadcast on
satellite across the nation there's a
little different schedule with both
we're going to be signing off and saying
farewell to our friends that are
listening on satellite but those of you
that are listening either on the
internet or you're watching on af tv or
better live television or
you're listening on a land-based station
we're going to be coming back for two
minutes of rapid fire bible questions
that you email in to us and so don't go
away otherwise for those on satellite
god bless and we'll study together again
next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
welcome back friends to our special part
of the program where we going to answer
your bible questions that have been
emailed in to us if you have a bible
question you can just contact amazing
facts send us an email through our
website well pastor doug we've got
several let's see how many we can get
through in the next two minutes question
number one was melchizedek god
well no of course melchizedek had the
spirit of god i'm sure but the bible
tells us that he was a king and he was a
priest of a particular territory and he
brought out food real food to abraham
and his friends and he received tithe
which back then probably wasn't money
but it was food and practical things
that they had won in the battle he was a
real person
and i just talked about that last week
if they want to go to facebook and see
my uh two weeks ago i dealt with that
okay next question that we have is a
question is is tithing only to be paid
to a church
or is it okay to give tithe to somebody
in need
well there's an example in the book of i
think it's deuteronomy where when they
went to a feast they could take a second
tithe
and they could maybe use that to help
with the poor along the way it was sort
of like charity during the feast times
that they'd they'd show but the the
first principle tai the bible says the
tightly tithe is holy to the lord and it
was given to the levites and that was
for the proclamation of the gospel it
wasn't to be just you know distributed
however a person said i'm going to send
it to my favorite ministry it was to be
going for the proclamation of the gospel
okay next question that we have how do
we know that good angels are with us
well god promises that i mean i think
there's things we can do to probably
grieve the good angels that are with us
but the bible says the angel of the lord
encamps round about those that fear him
and delivers them and it tells us in
psalm 91 he will give his angels charge
over you to keep you in all of your ways
and so
god does have guardian angels watching
us
okay next question i did cain mary's
sister and if so where did he find her
well he found her probably pretty close
to adam and eve yeah um he yeah he
married his sister
and
back then there was nothing wrong with
that technically adam sort of married
his sister and eve they both came from
the same family and it wasn't until the
time of moses that was forbidden to
marry close of kin
okay last question that we have pastor
doug could you quickly explain three
days and three nights that christ was in
the heart of the earth does that mean
the tomb no that's talking about the
sufferings of christ that began in the
garden when he said now is the hour of
darkness so that would be thursday night
friday night saturday night he was
suffering for the sins of the world it
included the tomb but not just the tomb
hey friends we love your questions we
look forward to getting more from you
and
tune in again we'll study his work
together next week
[Music]
you